vamos a ponernos un poco más cómodos en
la comprensión de lo que es una ecuación
diferencial y aquí tenemos justamente
una ecuación diferencial y no hemos
explorado aún cómo hallar las soluciones
de una ecuación diferencial pero digamos
que tú ves esto y alguien por la calle
no se te dice oye te daré una pista hay
una solución a esta ecuación diferencial
que es una función lineal y cuando
pensamos en una función lineal pensamos
algo de la forma m x más de verdad
entonces esa pista que nos han dado
nos dicen que desde la de esta forma es
una función lineal y lo que nosotros
tenemos que hacer es determinar qué
valores de m y qué valores debe
satisfacen la ecuación bueno más bien
hacen que esta función satisfaga la
ecuación diferencial y esto tiene que
ser cierto para todas x verdad que es
nuestra variable independiente entonces
lo que tenemos que hacer es sustituir y
ver qué condiciones debe cumplir tanto
la m como la d
para que se satisfaga la ecuación
entonces por ejemplo si nosotros
calculamos la derivada de esta función
que es lo que tendríamos la derivada de
nuestra función con respecto de x sería
la derivada de mx que es m más la
derivada de una constante que vale 0
verdad entonces si si nosotros queremos
hallar mb que hagan que esa función
cumpla la ecuación diferencial
tendríamos que del lado izquierdo sería
m
esto sería menos 2 x
tres veces pero en este caso como nos
dijo esta persona en la calle es mx + b
y finalmente restamos 5 muy bien
entonces aquí viene la parte interesante
de este problema porque bueno quizás
deberíamos ir desarrollando esto para
ver si y simplificando tendremos ms
menos 2x y ahora desarrollamos esta
expresión esto sería 3 m x + 3 b menos 5
verdad o lo que es lo mismo podríamos
poner esto como m igual a podríamos
agrupar nuestra equis verdad entonces
tendríamos 3m -2 aquí está esta 3m y
este menos 2 que multiplican a x
más la parte constante verdad que es 3 b
menos 5 entonces piensa digamos de la
siguiente forma del lado izquierdo
nosotros tenemos una constante que es la
constante m y esto debe ser igual a una
constante por x más otra constante pero
debe ser cierto para todas x entonces si
nos damos cuenta esto que tenemos del
lado derecho es algo que cambia con con
x mientras que del lado izquierdo
tenemos algo constante entonces eso nos
dice que esta parte que depende de x
debe digamos de alguna forma debe
desaparecer verdad y una forma de que
esto desaparezca es justamente si este
coeficiente de aquí el 3m -2 se vuelve
cero o bien otra forma de pensarlo es
que esto lo podemos escribir como 0 x +
gm debe ser igual a algo por x más otra
cosa entonces tenemos que igualar los
coeficientes verdad pero tendría que ser
3m -2 y m tendría que ser 3 b
los 50 son dos formas de pensarlo y lo
que tenemos es justamente que 3m -2
tiene que ser igual a cero o lo que es
lo mismo tres m tienen que ser igual a
dos o bien m tiene que ser dos tercios
verdad y finalmente con esta información
que ya ya tenemos con este conocimiento
que hemos adquirido ya podemos
determinar quién es nuestro nuestra
verdad porque tendríamos entonces que b
tiene que ser igual a tres b menos cinco
de la misma forma que 0 fue 3m -2 verdad
entonces m tiene que ser tres b menos
cinco o lo que es lo mismo
m ya vimos que era dos tercios entonces
dos tercios tiene que ser
3b menos cinco y algo que podemos hacer
para eliminar este 5 digamos este menos
5 es sumar justamente cinco de ambos
lados pero vamos a hacerlo en términos
de tercios verdad podríamos nosotros
sumar quince tercios
quince tercios son justamente cinco
entonces eso se cancela y también
tendremos que sumar quince tercios del
lado izquierdo esto nos dice que
diecisiete tercios que es lo que tenemos
del lado izquierdo es 3 b y finalmente
podemos concluir que nuestra b es 17
tercios entre tres que es 17 novenos
entonces ahí tenemos el valor de m que
ya está de este lado y el valor debe
entonces en resumen si le hacemos caso a
esta persona que nos dio la pista de que
la solución es de esta forma entonces ya
tenemos que valores de m&b satisfacen o
más bien hacen que la función satisfaga
la ecuación diferencial verdad entonces
hemos terminado en ese sentido hemos ya
concluido con la solución con una
solución de la ecuación diferencial
verdad que tendría que ser mx que en
este caso es dos tercios de x + b que es
17 novenos y por supuesto te invito a
que verifique es que en realidad esta
función de aquí esta función que depende
de x es una solución a la ecuación
diferencial